SO MUCH FOR NOT GOING IN PERSON
YESTERDAY.
THANKS.
BRIAN:  SO LET’S BRING IN
SOMEBODY WHOSE ASKINGS QUESTIONS
TODAY, THE SENATOR FROM
WISCONSIN, SENATOR RON JOHNSON
MEMBER OF THE SENATE FOREIGN
RELATIONS COMMITTEE.
SENATOR, WHAT DID YOU LEARN,
GLEAN FROM YESTERDAY, WHEN THEY
HAD JUST THREE MINUTES TO
QUESTION THE DIPLOMAT?
WHAT DID YOU LEARN YESTERDAY
THAT’S GOING TO HELP YOU TODAY?
>> GOOD MORNING, BRIAN.
NOT A WHOLE LOT.
I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY WE LEARNED
THAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO BLAME THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION FOR
DECISIONS THAT THEY MADE.
WHAT I FIND SO DISINGENUINOUS
ABOUT THAT BLAME GAME IS THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAD NO PROBLEM
OVERTURNING, FOR EXAMPLE,
SUCCESSFUL POLICIES ON THE
BORDER, WHICH HAD OUR BORDER
MOVING TOWARDS PRETTY GOOD
SECURITY.
HE HAD NO PROBLEM DISMANTLING
ALL OF THOSE SUCCESSFUL POLICIES
BUT THIS IS JUST THE ONE HE HAD
TO ABIDE BY.
IT’S COMPLETELY BS, AND IT’S
DANGEROUS FOR THIS COUNTRY.
AINSLEY: YOU’VE HAD SO MUCH
EXPERIENCE OBVIOUSLY BEING A
SENATOR.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN A WORSE
DECISION FROM A PRESIDENT?
>> NO, BUT THIS IS JUST ON TOP
OF OTHER BAD DECISIONS.
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN A
ROLLING SERIES OF DISASTERS.
THIS THE DISMANTLE OF THE
SUCCESSFUL BORDER POLICY SO
NOW WE HAVE A COMPLETELY OPEN
BORDER MORE THAN 6,000 PEOPLE
BEING APPREHENDED PER DAY THE
LAST FOUR OR  FIVE MONTHS
THAT DOESN’T COUNT THE KNOWN GOT
-AWAYS AT LEAST 600,000
PEOPLE WILL BE DISBURSED BECAUSE
OF THE OPEN BORDER THAT’S A
POPULATION GREATER THAN THE
STATE OF WYOMING SO THAT’S
DISASTER NUMBER ONE.
WHAT ABOUT ALL OF THE OUT OF
CONTROL SPENDING, THE INCREDIBLE
INCREASE IN OUR DEBT, AND NOW
YOU’VE GOT THE WITHDRAWAL, THE
SURRENDER, THE HUMILIATING
SURRENDER IN AFGHANISTAN.
IT’S JUST UNBELIEVABLE.
BRIAN:  BUT NOW THEY ARE ASKING
FOR $6.4 BILLION TO TOK RESET EL
AFGHANS, SO WHO DID WE GET?
WE’RE SUPPOSED TO MAKE ROOM FOR
95,000 PEOPLE, WHO ARE THEY?
>> WE DON’T KNOW, AND OF COURSE
, THAT’S WHAT’S MOST
TROUBLING IS BECAUSE WE WERE
HEARING FROM PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND, DURING THE
EVACUATION.
THEY DON’T WANT TO COME FORWARD
BECAUSE THEY VALUE THEIR JOBS
AND THEY WILL BE RETALIATED
AGAINST BY THIS ADMINISTRATION,
SO WHAT WE WERE HEARING WAS
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
THIS ADMINISTRATION WAS TELLING
US.
THIS ADMINISTRATION WAS SAYING
THAT THEY PLANNED FOR  EVERY
CONTINGENCY.
THIS WAS ORGANIZED.
THERE WERE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
AFGHANS THAT JUST FLOODED THE
AIRPORT.
NOBODY KNOWS WHO THEY ARE.
WE PUT THEM ON PLANES, WE PLAYED
THE NUMBERS GAME, SO MANY OF
THESE PEOPLE DIDN’T EVEN HAVE
ANY FORM OF ID WHATSOEVER.
I WAS AT FORT MCCOY, ASKED THE
COMMANDING GENERAL WHEN DID
YOU FIRST HEAR THIS WAS YOUR
MISSION?
HE SAID 10 DAYS AGO.
I ASKED THEM, COULD THEY SAY
THAT EVERY AFGHANISTAN THAT THEY
HAD RECEIVED, TAKEN IN HAD AT
LEAST AN  ID, THEY COULDN’T
ANSWER THAT QUESTION, SO WE HAVE
NO IDEA.
PETE: SENATOR WE LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR QUESTIONS TODAY GETTING
THAT SECOND ROUND HOPEFULLY YOU
CAN DIG DEEP OR  MAYBE GET THEM
TO ADMIT ONE MISTAKE WHICH THEY
HAVEN’T BEEN WILLING TO DO.
BRIAN:  LIKE THE LETTER AND THE
TRANSCRIPT OF THE PHONE CALL
PETE: SO MANY THINGS THAT HAVE
STILL GONE UNANSWERED WITH HIM
IN PERSON WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WATCHING BUT I WANT YOUR TAKE
YOU MENTIONED A SERIES OF OTHER
THINGS TO INCLUDE THE BORDER,
YOU MENTIONED 95,000 AFGHANS
THERE’S THAT MANY PEOPLE STILL
COMING ACROSS OUR BORDER A MONTH
AND IT’S SOMETHING THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS SEEMING
TO BE CONTENT DOING ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING ABOUT.
WE WANTED TO PLAY A SOUND BITE
OF ALLISON ANDERSON A TEXAS LAND
OWNER AND THE WIFE OF A BORDER
AGENT TALKING ABOUT THIS
SITUATION, AS THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO
TALK ABOUT ANYTHING ELSE, SHE
SAYS THE SITUATION IS GETTING
WORSE.
LISTEN.
>> MY CONCERNS ARE SAFETY, WHAT
WE ARE SEEING IS WE’RE
OVERWHELMED WITH ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS THAT ARE COMING
THROUGH OUR PROPERTY, OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD, OUR COMMUNITY, AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF MOMS WITH A LOT
OF LITTLE KIDS THE PEOPLE ARE NO
LONGER LETTING THEIR KIDS OUT TO
PLAY.
WE FOUND FOOTPRINTS OUTSIDE OF
OUR LITTLE GIRLS BEDROOM WINDOW.
I WOULD SAY 100% IT’S THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION’S FAULT.
HE NEEDS TO DO SOMETHING.
IT’S HYPOCRITICAL TO SIT HERE
AND MANDATE VACCINES AGAINST
CITIZENS AT THE SAME TIME, THE
BORDER IS COMPLETELY WIDE
OPEN AND THERE’S LITERALLY
THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
POURING OVER THE BORDER HERE
RIGHT NOW.
MANY THAT ARE INFECTED WITH
EITHER COVID AND/OR  HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED TO COVID OR  SYMPTOMATIC
TO COVID AND THEY ARE BEING
RELEASED INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
PETE: SENATOR THESE ARE
AMERICANS UNDER SIEGE, AS YOU
KNOW, AND THEY FEEL LIKE NO ONE
IS LISTENING TO THEM.
WHAT CAN, AT ALL BE DONE, AS
THIS CRISIS ALMOST GOES
UNCOVERED BECAUSE THERE ARE SO
MANY OTHER CRISIS CREATED BY
THIS ADMINISTRATION.
>> WELL THIS IS A SELF-
INFLECTED WOUND, CREATED BY
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
HE IS THE ROOT CAUSE OF THIS
PROBLEM, BUT HE’S BEEN
AIDED AND A BETTED BY THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA AND THE
SOCIAL MEDIA COVERING UP FOR
THEM.
THEY’VE ENABLED ALL OF THESE
DISASTERS, AND SO THE
ACCOUNTABILITY HAS TO COME
IN NOVEMBER OF 2022, I WISH IT
WOULD COME SOONER THAN THAT BUT
IT DOES NOT LOOK LICK THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS CHANGING
COURSE WHATSOEVER, AND OF COURSE
, THEY ARE ALL CONCERNED
ABOUT COVID DOING A MISERABLE
JOB QUITE HONESTLY, MANAGING IT,
BUT THEY ARE COMPLETELY
UNCONCERNED ABOUT PEOPLE WITH
COVID COMING ACROSS THE BORDER.
THEY ARE COMPLETELY CONCERNED
ABOUT ALL OF THE PEOPLE COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER QUITE HONESTLY
AND ENCOURAGING SO AGAIN, THIS
IS A CRISIS CAUSED BY
PRESIDENT BIDEN, BY HIS POLICIES
, AND THE ACCOUNTABILITY
HAS GOT TO COME IN NOVEMBER 2022
SWEEP DEMOCRATS FROM POWER.
THEY HAVE ENABLED THESE CRISIS,
THEY NEED TO BE SWEPT FROM POWER
IN 2022.
AINSLEY: SHE SAID THEY ARE
PUTTING THEM UNDERNEATH THE
BRIDGE THERE IN THE DEL RIO
SECTOR AND THEY ARE ABOUT 2,000
OF THEM DOWN THERE AND THEY PUT
THEM ON THESE BUSES AND DISBURSE
THEM THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTRY.
HOW DO THEY DECIDE WHERE THEY’RE
GOING?
>> THEY DON’T TELL US.
THEY DON’T TELL STATES THEY
DON’T TELL CITIES WHOSE GOING TO
BE COMING INTO THEIR
JURISDICTIONS.
THEY AREN’T ACKNOWLEDGING THE
DEGREDATIONS OF THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, OF THE UNVOLUNTARY
SEX SLAVES, AND AGAIN, THEY KNEW
ALL OF THESE THINGS.
THEY KNOW THAT IS THE PROBLEM
WITH UNCONTROLLED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND YET, THEY ARE
ENCOURAGING IT.
AGAIN, I CAN’T DESCRIBE HOW
FRUSTRATING IT IS THAT THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA WON’T COVER
THIS.
BRIAN:  IT’S AMAZING.
>> THEY ARE COVERING UP FOR
AFGHANISTAN, THEY WILL BE
CALLING PRESIDENT BIDEN A
PROFILE ENCOURAGE.
THIS IS THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA’S
FAULT AS WELL.
BRIAN:  THEY WANT TO TALK ABOUT
JANUARY 6.
AINSLEY: THEY PUT THEM UNDER THE
BRIDGE AND IF IT WEREN’T FOR
OUR DRONES WE WOULDN’T HAVE
HAD THE FOOTAGE OF THEM BECAUSE
THEY ARE OUT OF VIEW AND NO ONE
ELSE IS COVERING IT.
SENATOR, THANK YOU.
>> HAVE A GOOD DAY.
BRIAN:  SENATOR REAL QUICK, ARE
YOU GOING TO RUN AGAIN?
>> HAVEN’T MADE THAT DECISION
BUT I’M GETTING PRETTY POSITIVE
FEEDBACK.
BRIAN:  MAYBE ANOTHER SIX.
ALL RIGHT, THANKS SENATOR